okay ready to roll agile we are now
recording
thank you so much roy
welcome everyone thank you so much for
being here today
i am ajay i'm a solution manager within
the google cloud team
and my role here is to solve problems
that customers may have with the data
okay not that anyone has ever
uh we have a full half an hour to us
i would recommend get your choice of
beverage for this time of the day or
whenever you are listening and let's get
started
we will have time for q a at the end so
i do want to present
or at least give you pointers
and then we'll engage in the q a okay
you can quote me on this code behind
every successful application
there is a great database powering it
and this is my code it's my favorite
saying
and my next favorite saying is
applications go wherever the data
resides
it's the data that creates applications
stickiness to a platform
you may start with data modernization or
without modernization
uh but just don't stop at one but rather
let one drive the
other okay
now what's happening in the data world
and we have been saying this same story
for a long time data is just growing and
growing and growing okay
um it's growing in volume it's growing
in its velocity
and the variety the same old story right
and
now it's growing more with all the
digital transformation that's happening
which is propelled by the cova okay i
was looking at the fintech industry
it's one of the largest vertical
segments that we have
um it's
handling 100 trillion
transactions a day from around 20 000
financial institutions worldwide
and that's also unfortunately driving
the rise in
uh cyber security attacks and there's a
report from
fbi around how that is increased now
that's the number we don't want where it
is right now and the directionally where
the number is going
we are also seeing that customers
uh are coming to cloud in different
patterns
some are coming just as is
for reducing their costs
uh so they're taking their existing
databases moving it as is we call those
homogeneous database migrations and this
could be your existing oracles and sql
server or even in the open source world
your mysql and postgresql so you bring
it as is to cloud run it in the compute
or you take it to the managed services
that's definitely one
pattern that we are seeing
as customers get familiar with cloud
they then move on some move on to the
next step
and they say i'm going to break away
from this legacy databases
and use a cloud native database and
that's another pattern
but really the pattern that has picked
up
within the last year is where customers
are saying
we really want to try out a new business
model we know the power of cloud we know
the power of the google cloud native
databases and we want to transform our
customer experience
we have solutions for all these three
customer journeys
there's migration solution that will
help you migrate your databases
there's a modernization solutions that
will
help you
do a heterogeneous database
modernization
from ex for example from my sequel to
spanner
or oracle to spanner and then really
what today's focus in my talk will be on
transformation
where the customers are uh trying to
redesign their business models okay
so
i lost something here
let me
turn off that sorry
so on the transformation side when we
speak with customers
they have told us we love we love to
work with the cloud native databases
but
uh we don't have that critical mass of
developers who can develop
a workload a new workload a new
transformative workload
using those cloud native databases
and yes our migration cycles are long
because it's not just flipping the
switch over the database we got to look
at the application ecosystem we got to
test it we got to certify it we got to
make sure our compliances are all there
so this becomes like kind of a 9 to 12
month cycle right
and
then it's like what can we do to have
something quicker
so they asked us for help and yes indeed
we gave help
so this is the build with google
solution from google cloud
basically in this solution we are giving
you the building blocks so think of it
like if you were building a next
generation spaceship
you can build it with the smallest brick
the smallest block
from lego or anyone else right and you
will get there it will be a slow journey
you will have some fallbacks you will
have some risk to undertake but
eventually you'll get there
but what if you got some pre-built
wings of that spaceship or engine or the
nose
and these pre-built hardened components
you could use as is you could customize
them
for your specifications
that will help you build a spaceship
faster right it will accelerate your
journey there and also because these
pre-built components are from a vendor
like google it will mitigate your risk
because these are hardened these are
tested blocks now think of a database
application instead of the next
generation spaceship
every database application
has need to ingest data
then it has a need to make sure the data
is secure it has a need to process the
data it has a need to analyze the data
archive delete uh put it on a dashboard
those are like common data services that
every application
every database application needs and
what happens today is
that
as customers start building they have to
build all of that
and this is what build with google is
doing it's handing over those pre-built
blocks to the customers so that
they can accelerate uh their journey to
the cloud
okay
so in bob our first use case has been
how to build a payments gateway and
we'll go over what a payments gateway is
um and we'll look at the architecture
for that but basically this was a
request from our retail customers one of
the common problems of a retail customer
is the abandonment of the car and i've
been guilty of that as much as anyone
else when i have to give my credit card
information and my address 25 clicks i'm
like oh forget it i'm not going to buy
from here
70 percent of the customers abandon
their cart at checkout and this is true
for
the break stores as well as online
stores and if you go and talk to any
retailer they will give you the exact
dollar amount that it cost them okay
so that's a pure retail problem but then
that problem also extends into the
financial sectors
where the traditional banks are looking
for the next million customers and
they're coming to google and we have
only just a few
uh to say
uh apps with billions of customers using
them
and they're looking for
some new applications that will get hold
the attention of those millennial
customers
make them loyal customers
while being compliant okay compliance is
a very very
uh important thing in financial industry
so our payments gateway use case has a
proven reference architecture
that's been built on top of
the learnings from our own google
payments uh if you have ever been a
customer of google whether google play
youtube or a cloud subscription any
financial transaction
that you would have done with google
runs on that google payments platform so
we have gone and learned from that and
incorporated those learnings
in that reference architecture
and make sure that we share it with the
customer
using the google cloud technologies
uh that like spanner
now this google payment handles hundreds
of millions of transactions
it runs in 200 plus countries
around the world handling multiple
currencies
doing compliance across all these
countries so financial reporting
compliance reporting
uh treasury reporting currency hedging
all of that now we have taken a small
component of it and i'll go over that in
a short while with all of you
the next use case is basically our data
fabric by the way the payments gateway
reference architecture
is available today the version one of it
for version two we are doing more work
give
pulling together the data abstraction
layer
also double clicking into the risk
management system
and also putting some blueprints so
we'll go over those
shortly but let me introduce our second
use case before
uh we move on and that's building a data
fabric right
so a lot of banks as they are trying to
implement
uh the open banking standards they need
to move fast right
customers in retail and manufacturing
need to have a real-time view
of their entire supply chain
not just one part of it but the whole
thing supply chain
warehouse their partners their suppliers
uh down to the route right and the order
view and what selling their view
right
if if you walk into a store and see an
out of stock item right
um
that's a lot of lost sale for that
retailer right
and every retailer will tell you exactly
the dollar amount of it but not just in
retail telecom service providers as you
subscribe to a plan
the call detail record tells a lot about
your calling pattern stills and can give
the telecom service provider
some real insights into fraud and
prevent those fraud across the globe
okay
so having that cdr
having the health care provider have a
360 degree view
of the patients in real time
these are some of the needs coming from
our customers
and what we have with the data fabric is
a proven reference architecture
with building blocks for the common data
services so there'll be reference
architecture there'll be code snippets
available in
uh google cloud repo
documentation installation scripts and
in some cases a sandbox where you can
come and play with this these common
data services will help you do data
injection in real time
catalog management metadata management
data discovery
data lineage integration with security
services integration with analytics and
dashboard and reporting services
using the google cloud native databases
and then once you have that
infrastructure we expect the customers
to just
uh focus on
their
vertical use case their business logic
when they want to build
uh that fraud application they don't
have to worry about these common data
services they get that in the data
fabric they have to worry about what's
my logic what are my rules what are my
triggers uh to do fraud alerts to do
um an order to do like uh a pricing
promotion any of those vertical use
cases okay
uh for the gaming segment we plan to
publish uh some code templates we're
using spanner and firestore
for the retail
apart from
real-time recommendations and
personalizations
order management inventory management a
view of the supply chain
so
today we are going out uh with financial
use cases and retail use cases but we
are also keeping our eye on health care
and life sciences for a patient 360 a
cdr store for telecommunications bill of
materials for manufacturing just watch
this space there is a lot coming in uh
let me move on to the payments gateway
uh for those of you
who have used payments any credit card
debit card it gets acquired uh you may
be doing a point of sale terminal
it will get acquired and then processing
happens and then it gets handed over to
a payments processor which will then
work with the payer bank and pay bank to
settle that transaction
so there are a lot of components behind
this which uh make this happen
and uh
things like when you when you acquire
the transaction the very first thing
we do is to encrypt it because it has
your pii right you don't want to show
that credit card in real time
and then you would have some
orchestration services
uh you will be provisioning the users
verifying the users
the payment management system will be
going deeper into
the payment transaction it will be doing
some risk assessment in real time
whether to approve the transaction or
deny it or maybe cap it right based on
your profile
all of this is happening and getting
stored in a secure data storage which is
pci compliant
before it gets handed over to the
payment processor okay so between these
two vertical lines everything in between
is the scope of a payments gateway for
which we have put together the reference
architecture
uh for you to use it with deep technical
documentation in this refrigerator
reference architecture we are using gke
for all the application services
and we are using cloud spanner for all
your database needs because as you will
see the tenets that we had for this
design
around security around availability
around consistency the only product in
cloud that could meet it was cloud
spanner so talking about design tenets
uh
what we had was first and foremost
uh it was um
the
pci compliance sorry uh and basically uh
it was to maintain the secure network
maintain the cardholder data right uh
monitor it who's accessing what uh log
it and audit it but apart from security
itself it also needs um to be highly
available because you need access to
your money at all times
and your transaction needs to have
total integrity right if you are doing a
transaction for 40 dollars it better not
be 40.0001
okay
uh and then have performance and not
only performance but performance at
scale the throughput and the latency
okay and then the manageability aspects
the backup and the restore verification
and the disaster recovery
and it should be able to scale up and
down as your scale increases or you go
through a quiet period right
all of that
so
cloud spanner was the only database that
we could find which meant all of those
design tenants it gave us security and
compliance out of the box dlp
and c sequel
very very strong external consistency
scale of petabytes of database with
performance distributed
a strong
very simple administration
online schema changes
five nice availability with the
architecture that i'm sure you have
heard about
rpo equals zero in a financial in any of
these transactional industry you cannot
cannot lose any data okay
uh and fail failure recovery so uh and
on a global scale right with multi
regions
uh on the security and compliance side
the shared responsibility model very
well documented
on our website for pci dss
how do you isolate the
data
how do you encrypt at rest and in
transit
how do you manage your keys with kms and
hsm
how do you do logging who is doing what
an audit and monitor and do the pci dss
uh compliant
templates
uh
spanner integrates with iam our
for fine grain access it integrates with
vpcsc to achieve isolation of cardhold
data
cardholder data it encrypts the data
you can manage your keys with the cmac
and also audit logging and monitoring
i'm going a little bit faster keeping an
eye on the time there are dss
blueprints available today
uh for pci on gke and anthos and spanner
is coming very soon you will see it
announced uh on the scale and
availability i want to point out the
auto scaling uh that
spanner has
uh there are multiple ways to create the
regional cluster the standard or the
autopilot
and then we take we handle both
zonal failures as well as regional
failures and knock on world we have not
had a regional failure
uh same thing with spanner with auto
scaler and multi-region configuration
and replication
and dr all that is coming out of the box
for your use
uh the data fabric itself like the life
cycle of data
from injection to processing to storing
to analyzing and then getting value out
of it across the board with security and
governance
underlying all those services is what we
have
uh here is an architecture
there could be data coming from a number
of sources in batch mode in streaming
real-time structured unstructured data
semi-structured data we collect all of
that in a giant real-time
time series ordered synchronized
distributed even store built on top of
spanner okay
if you don't have the requirements that
spanner meets like you don't need that
strong consistency but you need very low
latency and a very high throughput this
architecture will also work on bigtable
you then give it to the data services
that you could be running in tke to do
your processing you can give it to
bigquery to do the pattern analytics
and to run those bqml models or archive
it in uh google cloud storage because
um you for a lot of industries there are
requirements to keep the data for seven
years ten years or life long like in
healthcare and you can explore the data
using on the dashboards using looker so
this entire range of services here is a
reference architecture for data fabric
that we will be building okay now here
are some of the requirements across the
industries so for retail you definitely
need the performance at scale especially
on a black friday cyber monday you also
need a single source of truth across all
the channels whether you are ordering it
with your app or on the web or in the
store if it tells you ajaya you have 25
doors i don't need 25 doors uh 25 hinges
right there i should be able to get
those 25 inches at a consistent price it
should not be that different channels
are giving me different prices right
i should be able to shop anytime i need
i don't want to see
come back later right
every retailer will tell you what's the
cost of down time and most of them have
staff trained in nc sql so having that
with spanner definitely helps similar
requirements with gaming
uh
hundreds of very popular game needs to
manage hundreds of vms thousands of vms
and you don't want to be doing that
manually and the game especially with
multi-player games located in different
countries the games have to be available
at all times and scale and not cost you
a back
uh fintech again all of those
as well as availability as well as
compliance as well as strong consistency
in a distributed environment across
multiple geographic regions
um
all of that so
here is another architecture very
similar to the data fabric architecture
you could be doing your banking from any
of these sources you write your apis you
have your transactional apps running on
top of spanner uh the transaction goes
out to to the payment gateway which
hands it over to the payment processor
uh or a core banking a legacy core
banking system
uh there is security and governance
underneath all this and then you can do
run your analytics and collect the data
in a data warehouse this architecture is
actually working at multiple customers
our typical winning profile has been and
this what i mean to say is
why did
these customers in these segments chose
spanner in the gaming strong consistency
leaderboard
requires very strong consistency right
if i'm the leader i'm the top of the
game i want to be there right
a very popular game has to scale
immediately and when there is no usage
it has to scale down automatically it
got to be available someone is playing
in taiwan someone is playing in
argentina it got to be available at all
times you have no tolerance for down
time
got to be able to change your schema
and
manage your shards automatically
fencer all of that plus very strong
consistent transactions
no tolerance for rpo right no tolerance
for that auto scale some of the
performance skills where 23 million
customers doing 25 million transactions
a day at 10 millisecond
latency or less latency in the retail
same thing multi-region consistency
availability i'm just a broken record
saying
um that over and over and over again but
those are the product capabilities in
addition what customers have enjoyed
working with us uh in google cloud is
the deep dive that we
do mutually equal in collaboration with
our customers on the capabilities and on
the roadmap we'll do architecture review
to tell them okay swing this way or this
way because something is coming on the
roadmap and very early engagement with
the google architects and engineers all
that helps nail down so in addition to
those segments we also have healthcare
customers running their emr records
doing the payments uh being compliant
because we are hipaa compliant keeping
the patient data the images all in
spanner and gcs
real-time decision making optimizing the
routes in real time that's low latency
high transaction throughput all those
applications can
run
uh on cloud spanner and these are the
this is not an exhaustive list of use
cases these are just some of the popular
ones running on cloud spanner today
so spanner is seeing a lot of momentum
you will recognize some of these brand
names in different segments
gartner recognizes it
but most importantly
we have not reached here overnight we
have had a long journey
today we are handling trillions of
requests an hour over exabytes of data
volume and thousands of databases
and basically with the innovation
happening at google this is basically
enabling customers to future proof their
businesses that's the thought i want to
leave you with
i'm going to be here for some more time
to answer any questions that you may
have
uh but i really want to thank you for
your time today and all of you are
extremely busy i appreciate you coming
here and listening to this and i'm here
to answer your questions thank you again
in order to uh ask a question you can
either raise your hand and i'll call you
out or you can unmute and
ask away
and if
nothing is there then roy will be happy
to
give us all some time back yes
i'll give it a few seconds just to see
if anyone's going to ask a question and
if not i will end the recording
all right so it looks like it was very
thorough um no questions so thank you so
much ajaya and thank you everyone for
joining i will end the recording right
now
thank you everyone thank you have a
wonderful rest of the week and we can
thank you